my guest tonight stars in the hit abc
series blackish
he also executive produces free forms
grownish
and is the host of to tell the truth
also on abc
he's everywhere all the time please
welcome our good friend
anthony anderson thanks for being here
in person thank you thank you for having
me
yeah um what's matter was it necessary
to get the anal swab when i came in
through the back door
we were doing that long before covid oh
oh
that's something i was requesting since
the 90s okay okay yeah
yeah did you mind it look
i have a scrapbook celebrity anal swabs
going
back to 19 1994.
so ebay watch out
it wasn't as invasive as i thought it
would be yeah well
wait till you leave there's one on the
way out oh okay okay and that's a
different stick
let me ask you a question first of all
thanks so much for coming in person
i always love talking to you and we're
doing a lot of these on zoom
and then it's like uh christmas for me
when they say
when they tell me anthony anderson is
coming in person and i get to hear
that laugh and experience you live
that's so exciting well not like you
know not unlike many of your other
guests who come here live i needed to
get out of the house
yeah yeah i just needed so it's not
about me yeah no it's about youtube
it's about youtube you know you're
you're like that friend that uh that
that someone could always use as an
alibi
i'm just going out with conan
and no one no one's that threatened that
you're hanging out with conan
nothing sexy is going to happen no
ladies are going to be around
nothing too crazy is going to happen
right right well a lot to talk about
first of all
um i've been thinking i i had the good
fortune
of taping a podcast with you i want to
say about a month and a half ago and it
was
absolutely you were hilarious you were
not it was non-stop laughs the whole
time
and i think we spent all of it talking
about your mom yeah your mom
is taking over um obviously she's a big
part in your life
but she seems to have become a
phenomenon
in her own right now yeah she she she
has become man you know
um and you know this was always her
dream conan
you know to do what we're doing yeah and
to do what she's doing now
and it never panned out for her main
reason she's a horrible actress and
really
doesn't have the talent
nor the discipline that it takes to make
it right
here's the issue the issue is she's
showing up in places i wouldn't expect
your mom to show up
she's on social media she posted
uh a tick tock silhouette challenge
and i first of all i'm if i went on tick
tock i stay off tick-tock because my
kids would just
be they would disown me if i went on
tick-tock no one wants to see me on
tick-tock
your mom is killing it on tick-tock she
is man
uh i had posted it on on my social media
page man and it got
you know close to a hundred and fifty
two thousand views man
and that was right i love that you know
my my mom is doing her thing
now wait a minute let's let's show it we
have a clip here
of your mom's tick tock challenge this
is a silhouette challenge i guess it's
called yeah it's a silhouette challenge
let's take a look at this and see what's
going on
playing her favorite game bingo
[Laughter]
she's grabbing her nipples right now
they're down around her waist yeah
[Laughter]
now wait a minute wait a minute first of
all uh that was very entertaining
second of all when it cuts to the
silhouette i know it's supposed to be
kind of erotic and sexy i was also
frightened
it had like it had a horror movie vibe
about it well
it was horror like as a son watching
that not
knowing my mother not knowing what she
was about to expose or show
and you know i don't know uh first of
all how does she even know about this
a mom your mom my mom they're not
supposed to know about
this [ __ ] well my mom is a young 67
man she still has her ear to the street
she uh
rarely hangs around people her age uh
and and just likes to be amongst the
people man you know
uh we have lots of cousins uh young
cousins she has
lots of um uh young nieces and nephews
that that are around her they keep so
she picks up on
how young people speak how they behave
she's she's picking up on all that she's
picking up on that man i
remember one time i was telling her to
meet me someplace
and she was like what time i need to be
there i was like he's like say less i
was like whoa
whoa whoa who you've been talking to
say less i love that yeah say less say
less isn't a put down right no it's not
a put down it's like i got you
you don't need to say any more say less
right i don't think that's going to go
over at my house
when i go home and my wife says okay
well anyway i was thinking and i go
say less you're going to hear about a
homicide
a homicide conor bryan was shot and
killed today
yeah you have to know when to work it in
yeah i would not know that yeah yeah
now is your mom is she gambling still
because i know she loves gambling but
there's proven she started off her tick
tock playing bingo but is she owning
is she i know she's playing bingo but
can she
she can play for money she can play for
money uh they just recently opened
um uh her bingo hall this past monday
so she's back oh so what has she been
how has you been playing bingo
while the bingo hall the bingo hall must
have been closed for a year the bengal
hall has been closed for a year
uh she found this place out in rosemead
uh where they converted a drive in to
drive in bingo
you roll up in your car they give you a
pad and they give you your um
your your daubers or or your uh your
place match to play
and uh they uh would read the numbers
and it would come over the radio station
like you know the movies
yeah yeah yeah and if you got a bingo
you lay it on your horn and then they
would come over and check your car
[Laughter]
you know i gotta say that maybe should
continue even after everyone's vaccine
even after everyone's vaccinated right i
i mean we should keep doing it that way
i would love to go to drive in bingo man
with my mom yeah the idea of leaning on
the horn
yeah yeah yeah that that's fascinating
she invited me but i was like nah i'm
cool
yeah yeah you've got other things to do
i got other things to do you know it's
funny because a lot of uh
there's like this i don't know it's kind
of like a celebrity
uh fantasy of i'm gonna buy my mom a
house
you know yes and i'm gonna uh you know
that's like the dream
like i'm gonna make it in the business
and then i'm gonna go up to my mom and
i'm gonna say mom
here are the keys right and it's this
and i know that you
wanted to do this for your mom that was
the dream but
you encountered some difficulties that
was the dream well
yeah i encountered some difficulties
that but that came later though the
dream
was okay i'm gonna get my mom a house
and then things didn't
happen as quickly as i wanted them to
and then my mom got tired of waiting she
was like you know baby you ain't got to
buy me in the house you know just
keep funding my bingo habit i would say
[ __ ] i'd rather buy you a house
it's cheaper that way uh but so recently
uh with my mother's newfound fame and
all of this
and my mother could afford to um
go out and buy her own home on her own
now but she's still holding my feet to
the fire on this promise
that i made to her years ago as a child
that i would buy her house whenever i
made it
so i got a realtor and we're looking at
places out by my mother where she lives
in south bay area bellflower where we
grew up
in l.a and compton and all that and then
she
then i recently purchased a new home and
i'm having it remodeled and she's like
what you gonna do with this house
i was like i don't know she was like let
me move in it i was like i think about
it so me saying i'll think about it was
her saying
i'm moving to anthony's house he moving
out he gonna give it to me i was like no
mom that's not what i said
i want to live out by you okay marilla
just starts looking out for
for homes in the valley we find
five homes my mother goes to the first
one as i'm walking out of the house to
go meet her at the house
i'm not moving in this [ __ ] well mama
why
wait this speaks too narrow she went
there ahead of you she went there ahead
of me got there ahead of me to
to scout the place out i was like mom
the realtor's there
why don't you just go in the house right
and look at it yeah nice moving into
this [ __ ]
mama the streets are too small i don't
know about this [ __ ]
mama just just going like she wouldn't
even go inside she wouldn't go and i
said mama
you're there already you're she's
literally parked in front of the house i
said mom just walk in
i was like okay you don't have to get
this one just walk in it may
spark something for something that you
may like down the road now
meet me at the next one i was like all
right so
before i could even get directions to
the next one my mom is already at the
next one
and called me she said boy what is wrong
with you
why you got me looking at this place so
i i found a nice little compound because
my mother
my mother doesn't want to live alone she
wants her assistant to live with her she
wants my sister to come by right so i
found a nice
compound on an acre of land that had
three a main house and two satellite
homes on it
it needed a little tlc sure but i wanted
my mother to see
what you would get for the same amount
of money that you're going to pay down
down there someplace what should we get
in the valley come look at it and she
was like
why are you sending me here look at all
this dirt and trees and [ __ ]
what's wrong with trees are good
yes i was like mama so she didn't even
go into that one
there was a third one and she drove up
to that one and said you know what
this [ __ ] too far i'm not moving out in
the valley and left
so what do you do i never left my house
that morning
[Laughter]
she never let me leave the house to get
to the properties to look at
so i removed myself from the home search
and she found a home in uh carson
or torrance uh down the street from
drunk bobby her best friend
uh bobby she lives on the west side
of the street and my mother lives on the
east side and it's about like an
eight-minute walk to each other's homes
so um that's where she is and
uh she called me the other day and she's
like they're remodeling
uh i'm in escrow uh
i'mma call you or they gonna call you
let you know when you need to write the
check
i was like okay mama that's that's
that's what i'm gonna do she's moving in
april
april 13th but it's not a good i mean
obviously
the fantasy is mama you've always wanted
your own house yes i have and you toss
through the keys
yeah you've got one and it's and of
course it's not going to be that simple
no but i know on that day when she moves
in
and you write that check that's going to
be a great feeling no it is
it is it is i got to do that when i
first made some money i wanted to buy my
mom a car
and when i told her i was told her when
i was a kid mom someday i'm going to buy
you a car
and i remember this is going to be
really fun and i took my mother and she
kind of talks like she's very proper
right and she talks a little like this
and i took her to the dealership and i
said
do you like any of these cars and she
said i don't like the color black
not was it was it was like i don't like
black cars and i don't like blue cars
i don't want black or blue and i'm like
you're ruining the moment
which which one do you want it can't be
black and it can't be blue
i know i'm just trying to have this be
like a fun well i just think
black it looks like you're going to a
funeral and blue it gets very dirty
i know you've told me that and so we
couldn't we couldn't get past that
so you didn't get her no no we did get
her a car but it was taking all the fun
out of it yeah
you know instead of like i can't believe
this is happening and hugging me right
right yeah that that's not that's how it
is with my mom and
because of her bingo habit i just can't
give her cash
i can't write her a check you can't give
her you really can't give her an atm
because that's gonna get out of control
yeah i can't i can't give her the money
i can't trust her with the money to go
buy
whatever it is that i said i was gonna
buy her so that's why she's having
the the bank and the escrow people call
me and i just send it to them
yes but i got my mother a car once yeah
yeah never again
no right no never again
i'm gonna tell you a car story my mother
called me one day
uh she had a little suv
and she said maybe i want to get a new
car i was like okay i'll help you get a
new car then if that's the case
you know let's take that one let's go
trade it in see what we can get for it
and i'll get you something she said no
i'm gonna keep this one i was like okay
but
mom what why are you going to keep it
she's like well
you know just in case my friends need
help moving
i was like mom you're 63
what friends of yours need help moving
at this age i'm just going to keep it
i'll say mom that does that doesn't make
sense for you to still keep this car
note
go out and have me buy you another car
just so you can keep this car around in
case your friends
need help moving i was like yo friends
i was like go to them and ask them to
help you buy a car then if that's what
you that's what you're holding out on
yeah so um i didn't get her a moving van
i didn't i didn't get her the second car
and so she went out and got it on her
own and still has the suv
to help her elderly friends move in case
they need to move i have to give you
credit though because
your mom she's a character she doesn't
sound like she's always
easy but you are working with her
oh she is co-hosting to tell the truth
with you
yeah i couldn't do that i could not work
side by side with one of my parents i
love them but they couldn't do that
what's it like how did she get this gig
you know what uh
i had already had the gig we hadn't
started production yet
uh and i got a call that steve harvey
wanted me to do celebrity family feud
and i was like okay cool so i bring my
mom
uh my brother my sister-in-law and my
aunt
and so it's the five of us and the first
question out of the gate
where would a naked magician pull a
rabbit out of and i'm up there with
steve another contestant with my hand
boom i hit the buzzer first anthony i
was like his ass steve
boom number one answer all right yeah
turn to my mom and then hey
we don't play baby we gonna play oh
steve we gonna play so we go back
known steve 25 years he's known my mom
just as long so there's a
there's a relationship there so he knows
something wild is about to come out of
my mother's mouth
he was like miss doris uh question to
you is where would a naked magician pull
a rabbit out of and she looks steve dead
in his eye and says
his nuts steve it's nuts
that's not possible exactly
steve cries shuts down production for
maybe
five to seven minutes the crowd is going
crazy we gather ourselves
of course the answer's not up there we
end up losing to tony braxton and her
family as one
as one does yes so the producers come
over
who actually produce family feud they
produce it's fremantle they produce
uh to tell the truth they're anthony
we'd like to talk to you about your mom
i was like guys
i'm sorry i told you she was a live wire
i was like you know what
you never know what's going to come out
my mama i'll talk to her everything is
cool and i'm like no
no no no we loved what she said we loved
what she did
what do you think about her your mom
being your co-host
oh wow on to tell the truth i was like i
think you can write a bigger check than
i can and i'm all cool
this is great this is going to take care
of all your problems yeah and
and that is how my mom got on to tell
the truth
good for her and we've been rocking out
for
six seasons now that's incredible yeah
yeah
and so she's able to travel is she
blowing a lot of that money on bingo
uh you know remarkably not my
my mother has never been one to save
money you know as soon as she gets it it
goes out and that's why we never had
anything as kids growing up but that's
another
story for another couch and another
therapist yeah yeah um
but no so my mom's my mom has done well
yeah she's been able to save uh she's
been able to get her credit right
she's been able to uh get a financial
plan in order
uh and she's about to buy her own her
her own home
and uh and have money in the bank so
yeah she's learned
it took 67 years but it she's learned
you should start hitting her up for
money
she would never give it to me cody my
mother would my mother would call me at
you know when i had the height of me
making movies
um let's say kangaroo jack kangaroo jack
made a hundred million dollars
my mother always thought that 100
million dollars the vast majority of
that went to me
yes so my mother would call me she said
boy kangaroo daddy at 100 million
you think you could let me hold 50 000
no mama
that's not how it works it's not how it
works it's actually my mother would call
me for 50 grand at a time
conan yeah yeah you got to move around
fast you got to change your number yeah
make it very hard well listen this has
been an absolute joy next time bring
your mom
it's over yeah we did it that we did it
we spent you know what i don't think we
all we did was talk about your mom so
again
every time you and i talk it's your mom
so next time
if you're running late you can send her
a head okay but she'll probably call you
and be like i'm not doing this shitty
show
mom just go inside no no no there's too
many trees there's dirt
i don't want this [ __ ] uh blackish airs
tuesdays at nine on abc
grownish aired thursday nights at eight
on free form and is available
the next day on hulu anthony anderson
you made my day thank you so much it's
always a pleasure conan always a
pleasure thank you